you certainly must have had some
conversations with harry about it and
have your own suspicions
as to why they didn't want to make
archie
a prince what are what are those
thoughts
why do you think that is do you think
it's because of his race
during meghan markle and prince harry's
90-minute interview with oprah winfrey
the duchess of sussex revealed that it
was the royal family's decision
not to make archie a prince and implied
his
race was a factor in those months when i
was pregnant
all around this same time
so we have in tandem the conversation of
he won't be
given security he's not going to be
given a title
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
this special is going to be the first
time we hear megan talking about race
and how racism has affected her
especially during her time as a working
member of the royal family
she'll also be addressing racism in the
uk which takes a slightly different form
to other parts of the world including
the us while speaking with oprah about
the conversation over archie's title
megan said there were concerns about how
dark her son's skin might be
but she wouldn't reveal who in the
family was initiating those
conversations
i think that would be very damaging to
them we know that one of the things
megan is going to be asked about
is the is the subject of race what it
was like being a biracial woman marrying
into one of the oldest establishments in
the world
the house of windsor um there will be
people that are very nervous about that
and oprah wouldn't be doing her job of
course
if she didn't ask the difficult
questions harry later confirmed those
discussions took place
but he wasn't comfortable sharing
specifics
that conversation i'm never going to
share
but at the time at the time it was
awkward i was a bit shocked
um can you can you tell us what the
question was no
i'm not comfortable sharing that harry
added that the royal family didn't want
his child to have the title of a prince
or a princess
and honor his older brother william's
three children all
received and in the last few months of
megan's pregnancy
she says she and harry were told their
child wouldn't have security either
the idea of our son not being safe
and also the idea of the first member of
color
in this family not being titled in the
same way
that other grandchildren would be you
know the other piece of that
conversation is
when you're the grandchild of the
monarch so when harry's dad becomes king
automatically archie and our next baby
would become
prince or princess also it's not their
right to take it away
i think for both of them the attitude is
so be it
because for so many years the whole
world has spoken about harry and megan
but they haven't been able to speak
themselves and
you know who can forget that question
from oprah in the first preview were you
silent or were you silenced
to megan and we're really going to hear
the extent of that and i think that when
people do they'll have a much better
idea of what they're up against
following sunday's tell-all special
oprah appeared on monday
cbs this morning and revealed that while
prince harry would not share the
identity of the member of the royal
family who made comments about his
child's skin color
he did share who wasn't behind those
conversations
he did not share the identity with me
but he wanted to make sure that i knew
and if i had an opportunity to share it
that it was
not his grandmother mother nor his
grandfather
that were a part of those conversations
in another bonus clip from the interview
shared on monday megan opens up about
the scrutiny she
and her sister-in-law kate middleton
received from the british press
explaining that there is one major
difference
unfortunately if members of his family
say well this is what's happened to all
of us
or if if they can compare what the
experience that i went through was
similar to
what has been shared with us kate was
called weighty katie waiting to marry
william while i imagine that was really
hard and i do
i can't picture what that felt like this
is not the same
and if a member of his family will
comfortably say we've all had to deal
with things that are rude
rude and racist are not the same
meanwhile harry said it would have made
a
huge difference if his family had
acknowledged the racism facing his wife
there's a lot of people that have
seen it for what it was yeah yeah
a lot of people like it's talked about
across the world
yet the the very people that don't want
to see it or can't see it
choose not to see it